SUSAN WOJCICKI: And now I'd like
to invite Anna Patterson
to come up on stage.
Anna Patterson has worked on
some of the biggest, most
ambitious projects I've seen at
Google, and she's going to
tell you a little
bit about them.
Anna is Vice President of
Engineering and Artificial
Intelligence.
What an amazing role
and opportunity.
So let's please welcome
Anna onto the stage.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNA PATTERSON: So I'm here to
tell a little bit of hacker
stories from the trench, and I
think with a main theme of
perseverance.
I saw that the ENIAC
programmers, how they got a
circuit diagram in
order to program.
My first programming job out of
school was for the F-15E,
and we would test our software
the best you can on something
that wasn't flying.
And then we'd invariably
need to put in patches.
And just like the ENIAC, you had
to toggle in the program.
So it was very scary since
people's lives were
depending on it.
But also I was thinking
about how
source control has evolved.
Of course, my first programs
in high school
were on punch cards.
But at home, I was really
fortunate that my dad brought
home a Commodore Pet computer,
and he encouraged us to
experiment and write
a program on it.
And I wrote a really, really
horrible, terrible video game,
and it only had 8K of memory.
So I stored the program state
in the corners so they were
flashing weirdly.
And, you know, I guess it was a
standard trick, I found out
much later.
But I was from the suburbs of
Saint Louis, so I wasn't
really part of a burgeoning
hacker community.
I eventually got my PhD in
computer science at the
University of Illinois,
Champaign.
And then I became a research
faculty member for John
McCarthy, the founder of AI.
And I see several people here
who know me really well, and
so you'll appreciate when I say
that John McCarthy made me
do something how hard
that must have been.
So he made me look into this
area called phenomenal data
mining, where you're given
facts and relations, and
you're given a big data set.
Big was very small
in those days.
And then when you learn new
correlations, you can explain
these new correlations in
terms of underlying
phenomenon.
So that's where it got its name
and that technique is
still in use.
But everybody was leaving the
department to start companies,
so we were pretty much like
the last ones out when the
lights were turning off.
And I co-founded, in 1998,
a web mining company.
Because the web was so big at
5 million pages, we thought,
how are people going to be able
to get around this thing?
And so we had an idea to make a
automatic taxonomy and kind
of lead people to what questions
were answerable on
the web and what ones weren't.
Because in those days, trust
me, there weren't really
recipes on the web,
but the taxonomy
around Linux was deep.
So we got angel funded to do
this just in time for the
dot-com crash.
And so I tried to figure out
what my other passion was, and
I said, mobile is just
about to take off.
So I moved into the mobile area
in 1999, just in time for
the telco crash.
So after killing two industries,
I was actually--
I had a one-year-old, and I
was four months pregnant.
And of course, I was unemployed
and I was actually
living in Pavni's guest room,
who's in the front row.
And so the doctor said,
you know, you need
to be on bed rest.
And I said, have you ever
heard of programming?
And he hadn't.
And I said, it's a lot
like bed rest.
So I volunteered at the Internet
Archive, and they
have snapshots of the
web over time.
So as such, especially
in 2001, it was much
bigger than the web.
It had 30 billion web pages, and
the live web at the time
maybe had 5 billion.
So I did a history-based search
engine that launched at
like, 12 billion pages, and you
could look at how terms
change over time.
So you could dial back to 1997
and search for a term like
"Clinton," and you'd see all
these co-occurring terms in a
graph and how they changed over
time, and it was very
presidential.
Dialing it up to 1999, it wasn't
quite as presidential.
And then moving forward to
today, everything is about
Hillary Clinton, if you search
for Clinton, when you look at
the popularity of the
things on the web.
So it was a really interesting
project, and I was doing it as
a volunteer.
And four days after it launched,
various companies
wanted to talk about
acquiring it.
So I go from volunteer,
stay-at-home mom, to the world
of corp dev.
So that was really fun.
So that's how I wound
up at Google.
And at Google, I really wanted
to unlock some global and
local information.
One of our examples was about
these small towns in Germany
with their local Oktoberfests
and how that information was
really important to them.
And we weren't quite
big enough to get
everything to everyone.
And so at Google, we evolve our
system so just when one
system launches, we would
start a new one.
So when one such system just
launched, I came up with the
idea for TeraGoogle.
And speaking of thinking big,
probably 95% of people said,
why would we ever need
a search system
for a trillion pages?
And of course, the founders
were like, is that all?
So at the time, it was
very cost efficient.
When it launched, it was about
50 times cheaper than our main
line index.
And at the same time, some of my
web ranking team went off,
and they shipped one of our
early deep-learning projects,
which was around ads broadening,
like once you bit
on one keyword, what other
keywords do you--
might be interesting.
So after having my fourth child,
I did what everybody
does when they have four
kids, and they're
on maternity leave.
I decided to start a company.
So I started a company--
Cuil.
And we really wanted to bring
like a really high-res, rich
experience to people with high
bandwidth, and a really low
bandwidth experience to people
who had feature phones.
And so what we did around the
low bandwidth experience is we
summarized things so that a fact
that appeared on tons of
web pages was on top in kind
of paragraph format with a
bunch of references down to much
rarer facts that had much
fewer references.
So after Cuil, I returned to
Google where I became one of
the first 100 engineers in
Android, because this time, I
was pretty sure the
mobile revolution
was going to happen.
But it wasn't a sure thing.
I mean, at that time, Android
had sold 40 million phones.
And of course, today it was
announced that Android now has
900 million.
I was part of the team that
helped launch Google Play on
Play tablets.
And very recently, like two
weeks ago, we shipped a native
search architecture onto the
phone to index all the local
data so that when you're
offline, you can have access
to it, and some data never
leaves your phone.
So a lot of people say, wait,
Google's so good at search.
Why didn't you just compile
the thing and
put it on the phone?
Well, the phone is kind of like
my early Commodore Pet
computer, not quite as bad,
but compared to a
data center, it is.
And each of the programs can
only have 20 meg resident in
memory and the executable is 500
meg as hard constraints.
So trust me when I say that
Google search system, its
executable is bigger
than 500 meg.
So when we look at this system,
because of the success
of Android as a compute cluster,
it's actually over
500 exahertz of computing
power, which is way more
powerful than the human brain.
So last autumn, I moved over
to our new AI area, where
recently Ray Kurzweil
joined us.
And he says that the AIs that
humans create are going to
leave the Earth at light speed
and populate the universe.
So we're not just working on the
most important project on
planet Earth, but
in the universe.
So I do want to encourage the
Techmakers out there, women
and men, to really reach for the
stars and use technology
to help shape the world.
Technology is a very powerful
platform in order to help
people and enable change.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]